The Joe Rogan Experience well I gotta
give it a Sloan he took all the hits and
all the bumps and oh he was an animal
yeah I kind of messed his collarbone up
you know by accident but you know it's
he was amazing I mean I remember when I
was gonna go do that film Vince McMahon
senior fired me because of that
because of that movie because what well
I'd got the call I didn't know there was
a senior oh yeah I've been senior that's
what I started working for brother yeah
so it's not the Vince McMahon that's an
old guy no his dad was a star I first
when I first went to when I first went
to New York in 78 Vince McMahon senior
had a couple Phil zacho and a couple
partners and then he Jr
had one building I think in Cape Cod and
Vince would come in once every three
weeks he'd hold a stick like Mean Gene
you know so when I first started there
were 70 and however I lasted until
probably mid 80s and I told Vince senior
I got this crazy call to come out and do
a slow move Stallone movie first I was
in the dressing room and Gorilla Monsoon
and gave me the note I'm like yeah right
I threw it away because you know Sloan
was like 150 feet tall in the public
size and I saw Rocky one of Rocky too I
was like oh my God
so I said you had another wrestling joke
you know like pooping in my bag or
putting locks on my stuff you know so I
split to Japan for like eight weeks and
when I came back again to TV again in
Allentown they hand me a Western Union
letter this time from Stallone
so I flew out there and talked with him
and got in the ring with him and did a
couple things if you want to hear about
that that's a little different but what
would you do well when I went out there
I just had my nose broke in Japan for
like the second or third time
and when I went out there I was so
enamored and such a fan of his you know
he goes well you had a guy with a one of
those big cameras old school cameras you
know when I came in so I knew I was on
camera you know sorry at least I knew
that much back then and so he said let's
just get in there I can move around I
had jeans on and uh cowboy boots he goes
oh it's getting the ring like this so he
goes I'm gonna try to hit you I said
well if you want to you can hit me in
the nose because I saw the camera I
thought it'd be cool if he splattered my
nose that's how crazy I was it was right
after no surgery and I didn't have no
surgery it was right after my nose
broken again yeah I flew back to TV I'm
just assuming you had it fixed no no
Andre Andre would fix everything for you
you just stand behind me with a
something push everything down but so I
got in the ring he goes you know try to
hit me you know and so
when he went to hit me I just grabbed
him I said I don't want to hit you he
goes well hit me give me everything you
have I want I said no brother you don't
want that I said there's a certain
places I could I can hit you harder than
others
but if I hit you as hard as I can it's
not going to be cool because well give
me 50 of it I really don't want to I
sorry no no no no he was because they
were filming this whole day so I said
well you try to hit me I'll grab you
I'll bend you over and I hammer you
between the shoulders and I hit him I
probably gave him 50 percent as soon as
I made contact his face hit my cowboy
boots and he came up and his lip was
bleeding so that's perfect that's
perfect and so he was all excited you
know just because I hit him what a
psycho yeah and then we got out of the
ring and he goes you're a fake wrestler
you know bosses can kick a wrestler's
ass anytime get mad so he wanted me to
do an interview right so I did let me
tell you something you know that whole
right stick
so he goes I want you for the film
and I've never had an agent I've never
been in a movie I don't know anything he
goes I'll give you ten thousand dollars
to do the film
me being the negotiation genius that I
am I want 15.
you know I want 15 grand
so he gave me 14 000 and I signed
whatever oh my God he bargained with you
yeah wow yeah that's a [__] Sly you're
stealing yes I signed whatever you
wanted back in the day and that was it
but how rude yeah but no don't even give
him the 50 that's some but negotiations
like [__] right there but to go
backwards I had called Vince McMahon
senior that night from Fall River
Massachusetts because I was wrestling at
a high school in Fall River
Massachusetts
and I called Vince because he was my guy
we were we were really good friends on
top of him helping me give me the Break
Ben senior I called him in Fort
Lauderdale and I said brother I'm
leaving tomorrow to go to LA to do this
song he goes no you're not
he goes it's midnight now you have to be
in Charlotte at noon for TV with
Crockett because that sort of flaring
all those guys where he was sending me
down to that southern swing wrestling
thing
I said no I told you I'm not going to do
that you know I said I'm gonna go do
this movie and as soon as I'm done in
the movie I'll come back here so don't
come back you're never going to work
here again never so I went okay
I was single at the time I spent 20 to
24 weeks a year in Japan had a great
hookup in Japan being single with my
friends and all the stuff that was going
on there you know and um so I went to
Japan and the movie came out and all of
a sudden this guy Vernon from Minnesota
called me wanted me to come in there
so that was the place that everybody
wanted to go wrestling the AWA for
Vernon I don't know if you've heard of
it of course yeah four days a week
he pays you better than any of the
promoters and I just stumbled in right
behind this guy the crusher he was like
the Hulk Hogan of the Twin Cities and
that whole Saint Paul across Wisconsin
area with Brock Lesnar and Brad riggers
all those guys
so Crusher was walking around I was
walking in and I wouldn't let anybody
see my face my arms were legitimately
legitimately 24 back then and I threw my
arms up and I go hey if you guys want to
see my face you got to buy a ticket I
was trying to be a bad guy
and I do all my interviews with the back
to the camera my back was this wide back
there and they wanted me to wrestle
Jesse Ventura and Jesse Ventura is the
one that actually turned me Babyface as
soon as I walked up they booed the piss
out of him
and cheered me so I had that little run
in Minnesota for three years
then we're coming into New York you know
Laverne ghani was going to buy TV time
on Channel 9 and all up down the East
Coast that's when Vince Jr came back
and said hey brother you know I want you
to come back to New York and we had a
talk he came to my house in Minnesota at
five in the morning we shook hands and
we did that whole worldwide takeover